to be honest what goes to my head is
just like
don't disappoint the people who brought
me on oh wow that's a good one so it's
just like constantly like yo if this guy
said suing's good for this then I gotta
do it there's no other option that's
dope man and usually I [__] up but so it
doesn't work
[Music]
and welcome back everybody to another
awesome episode of be careful boys and
today we have Mr spin here with us
happy
uh but more importantly uh
wanted to talk first because Nick
usually backs out of his Jiu Jitsu
competitions and he had just signed up
for one so we're going to talk about
that yep look at that face I'm so glad
we caught him off guard I thought we're
gonna talk about Anthony's return
the next off the Record so watch this
one watch the other one but Nick
has been made a pack dude Nick Nick is
one of the most talented Fighters I know
you just don't know that many people
Brown dude you see me on Instagram
literally was my best friend Mark's
really good at grounding me and Floyd
Mayweather are like this I'm just the
only one that answers back to Bart
that's all what are they their best
friends everybody and Nick is really
talented and I'm really excited to see
him compete and really turn that drive
like up on Jiu Jitsu which which one are
you signing up for well we were talking
about doing one in December
December 2nd we're gonna do that one why
are you saying it like that because we
were talking about it maybe like both of
you hey so has he already signed up it's
already been like I don't know the
registration isn't open yet but when it
opens which is probably when does it
open because this video is going to come
out the day right after so it seems like
you've already yeah probably like
October maybe yeah but either way we're
gonna do it the whole Academy we're
gonna get a couple guys oh the whole
squads did it yeah so you have to come
compete with us and we all compete
together yeah because Bart already won
he's already a gold medalist yeah that's
true and Bart you know I think it's time
for BART to compete he's got a defend
his title no for real Bart this was
deflecting right away why did you sign
up for this why is the whole Squad do
this is this year like the the [__]
year to turn on the turbos yeah turn on
the turbo twin turbos honestly
I think Nick is so close to getting
black belt too I'm like I feel like if
he just pushes just a little bit hard
he'll get one of the the rarest things
that people have on this planet I think
that's part of the reason too like I
just want to push and push for it and
last year I did one in I think November
and I kind of had a really shitty
performance and I wasn't very happy
about it
um so was it too close to Thanksgiving
no no that's why
not even that it's just uh because you
get fat during Thanksgiving oh yeah
everyone gets lazy that's true this
one's even closer to Christmas yeah I
know what do you think made that a bad
performance right I just was being too
slow I was like I think in my head I was
just trying to be too calm because I
felt like anytime I compete I'm too like
amped up and I just do stupid [__] so
this time I was trying to be too chill
and then I was watching the video the
other day and I was like what the [__]
you know what you need to do
you need to match the energy of your
opponent and then take it over and use
it against them that's Jiu Jitsu he's
spear coach oh [__] he solved the
problem legendary Right sure not black
belt I I I am but I'm not giving one
okay I have a black people but no one
gave me one yet yeah yeah but like up
here
my question is do you just move when
they move or you really you got to be
thinking you gotta I think you just
gotta play your game I think that's the
number one thing yeah you'll play he'll
play the ludicrous technique yeah yeah
just like this the one thing that really
hurt like my biggest motivating factor
was
after the last tournament when my coach
looked at me and goes like
you should have beat those guys just
like that because you were better than
this like that was like a cake do you
think you got stage fright no not really
I don't I don't think I I think um
I think I probably shouldn't prepared
more prepare better deal with
preparation or you think you're just a
nice guy
I think I think it's both I think it's a
little bit I think it's a little bit
because
you don't murder you son of a [__] you
try to [__] molest my sister it's
nice guys it's like a nice way of saying
like [__] yeah yeah
I'm sorry I wrestle in high school and
then like in uh in the wrestling room
some of our roles are really hard and
it's because you know each other so
there's this comfortability and you're
pushing each other to be hardcore that's
kind of that's very true right so it's
like you can you have the hardest roles
with your teammates but then you go and
you meet someone at a new place they're
brand new and just as a normal human
being it's not normal I'm gonna [__]
conquer this man yeah it's normally like
hey what's up man where are you from and
oh you like it's like that but then you
slap hands the other guy might have the
I'm gonna conquer you feeling yeah and
then for you just like I kind of like to
warm up to that and then so you don't
want to be too mean but then a lot of
the initial it's like whoever strikes
first gets a big advantage and if the
other person strikes first and has a lot
of skill then you're already like kind
of backstepping and then now you have to
work that much more to even get back to
Newton so you seem to be naughty had an
agreement like yeah I I how do you
prepare to change that then well I think
it's just practice like the more you do
it the better you are at flipping the
switch and then your intention going
into it has to be like okay I'm gonna
compete and I'm gonna try to smash this
guy no matter what like I think the more
you do that over and over again the
easier it'll be for you to like do it
but isn't that kind of paradoxical
wouldn't you still be practicing hello
with your homies which is like the
opposite of what he's saying yeah but
game time is different like when you
compete in the tournament like you
that's why you need more volume to do it
like the more tournaments you do the
better you the more comfortable more
comfortable have you ever considered
that possibly you know
um you're a beta and you're not you're
not ready to oh trust me bro that's on
the Forefront of my brain but I'm trying
to change that I'm trying to change that
yeah I'm trying to get to the alpha
right now it's turbo time oh yeah I'm
all the way at the bottom
demon switch yeah exactly exactly
oh because if you talk to a audience
member usually overweight and never
fought before they probably will tell
you if that was me I would have all this
anger and just I would have killed that
fool yeah no for sure I think that's
that's definitely a thing and um I agree
with them no matter what because there
is a there's a little bit of Truth to
that just a little bit whether you think
it is or not but oh no dude I just want
to go compete I just want to go see
what's up I just want to test myself
will it help if you imagine your
opponent as being the cop who gave you
the jaywalking ticket oh am I oh [__] it
might force me to do something illegal
so this is the thing I've seen you fight
and then you do turn it on and then I've
seen you break down people's
um confidence and that was interesting
to see because I haven't really seen
that before like when people would spar
with each other and then like
like which is smart but then when I saw
Nick worked this guy he's six feet tall
bigger guy whatever and in the beginning
he had all this confidence he was
playing around he got a little serious
and at the end of it he just gave up
like you could see his Spirit just dying
and I was like oh [__] that is a
different thing that I've never seen
before
but um yeah at the at the same time
though I think like I've never seen you
actually be a bully
and I've seen bully Fighters yeah I
think it's helpful if you're competing
in a fighting sport it's helpful to be a
little bit of a bully I think so yeah
hell yeah but you're not I've seen both
my own [__] Sensei was a bully like
yeah but you're not I don't think you
have joy and and doing things like that
but that's why I'm a beta end the video
no no no because there's guys I talk to
that are Fighters and then or like
grapples or whatever and then when you
talk to them like oh like what like
drives you compete and they'll literally
say like when you see a man give up in
his eyes
you could literally see their eyes like
in their eyes they give up wait Nick
what drives you yeah that's kind of what
I'm wondering for me personally is so
corny but
I think it's just to like see where
you're at just to really test yourself I
think that's what drives me to like try
to do better oh okay I don't think I'm
motivated a real brown belt like that or
kind of yeah for my own [__] like my own
confidence of like oh yeah I've been
able to compete I can roll with anybody
and be competitive right and especially
I think that's the stage of my right now
but for me it's my own goal of like I
want to go win something that's it you
also thinks if you don't push yourself
to that extent that like maybe 10 years
later you might look back and regret
like yeah for sure and push myself
harder for sure and also I want to give
myself a long timeline because I think
the last time I didn't give myself a
long enough timeline because three
months like that [__] flies by really
quick to prep for it to prep for
something so if I'm gonna do something
I'm gonna try to prep for double the
time and and really give it a a college
try and see what happens can you walk
some of us noobs through what like a
prep is actually like well it's probably
just more frequency and training maybe
more specific stuff that you it's not
really dramatic and cool though no I
can't do that Bart can you help me I'll
try yeah okay so it's like say you're
trying to work a specific aspect of your
game so say in to relate this to dancing
if I was can and I was like a cutting
guy your boys are gonna practice those
isolations I'm gonna do my finger tuts
one day I'm gonna do my neck toe I
understand him hell I'll understand him
right now I'm gonna do my knee to hip
touch you know what I mean when do you
go to the butcher shop and [__] up a
piece of spare rib yeah oh that's
probably the last week that's like prep
and I'm just punching spare ribs dude
and my hand's gonna be all bloody for
punching bones no but so like it'll be
more specific like that so if you I
think you're trying to develop today's
video is brought to you by Lumi pow to
tell you guys the truth I don't wear
deodorant because I just never know
which one to buy and I'm really afraid
of all the chemicals and the [__] up
[__] that I watch all over Instagram
they go don't work don't use this one
it's got parabens don't do that it's got
medals don't do this and this your skin
absorbs herbs it and then you die and so
for me I just don't know it's
overwhelming especially when you go to
the store and you just see a whole aisle
of chemicals and choices and you're like
you know what I'd rather just be natural
so I annoy my wife and stay stinky but
thanks to Lumi I don't gotta be stinky
no more what's sick about Lumi it's
developed by an actual doctor OB GYN so
she developed Lumi for the [__] and so
if you know something that works for the
[__] which is a very sensitive area
generals it works for everything else so
right here in front of me I got the
whole body deodorances for pits privates
and Beyond and this one too that's the
gel version and this one is the stick
version and you can get the Stick and
rub it all over yourself so sensual and
it smells delicious too delicious it's
ph balanced no parabens and it works for
72 hours and it kills the odor at its
source this one's clean tangerine and
this one is lavender
I want a lick it and the Lumi starter
pack is perfect for new customers comes
with a solid Stick deodorant cream tube
deodorant two free products of your
choice like the mini body wash and the
deodorant wipes and free shipping as a
special offer for listeners as you guys
new customers get five dollars off a
Lumi starter pack with code Ocho at
lumide.com that equips over 40 off your
starter pack when you visit
lumide.com and use the code o t r which
you might see yourself in when you
compete of just kind of the game that
you want to play and then you're just
doing that over and over and over and
over again I think the volume is really
helpful do you remember the movie best
of the best hell yeah brother remember
I'll get an eye patch do you remember
when the train to go against team Korea
and [__] like that right and they're
like doing their physical stuff and
everybody's used to their physical share
there's a whole montage there's a whole
cutscene and everything but then they
bring in that like hot white chick who
comes in it's like we have to meditate
and train your minds and [__] like that
and that like blows everybody's mind oh
she's like the therapist right yeah yeah
I forgot about her isn't there like a
mental part that like needs to be
triggered because like especially I'm
assuming a transition from like a beta
mine to an alpha mine that's like a lot
of mental stuff not just like how hard
you work in the paint you know what I
mean oh well I think that comes I think
it comes from that like when you're
really uncomfortable when you're doing
like sprints on like the airline bike or
when you're doing like a bunch of rounds
with people and you have to do five more
rounds in your [__] dead tired but
you still got to find a way to play your
game no matter what I think that's
helpful because then you're like okay
I've went through the hard [__] your
training has to be harder than the
actual match that's the no matter an MMA
boxing whatever like I think that's
really important so as long as you make
it harder than your competition then
it's you should be fine I think you need
a hot therapist man will you be my hot
therapist you guys all tap into so like
you know when things get tough right
like when you watch [__] like [__]
Marvel Superheroes or whatever there's
like villains and and good guys and what
they tap into is different like you know
you ever get to that point where you're
like oh [__] I gotta [__] do this do
you tap into hate and anger or do you
tap into like another source Like Loving
happiness
in general or of course fighting
specifically in general when you need to
survive
is there a default I think for me it's
the not letting myself down oh that's my
number one thing I don't want to give up
like there's times where I look how
[__] exhausted as [__] but I know I
need to go train at five so I set my
alarm and I'm sleeping my alarm goes off
at five my phone [__] exhausted I
just hit snooze I'll be like oh my God I
can't this [__] little [__] just
[__] laying here this whole [__] [__]
you're [__] such a little [__] ass
[__] and I'm like [__] I love myself
really yeah I got I think I have to talk
to myself like me me letting myself down
like hurts me so bad like I think
because I had so many of those moments
that Nick talked about so like you know
what I when I wrestled in high school
like I'm Mr Nice Guy too hard rolls in
the gym competition I'm just like nice
and I'm like like there's like almost
two kinds of rollers people that go a
hundred percent and then dial it down to
where this person's at like if this
person's like is a black belt he'll go
100 all black belt skills and go oh okay
this guy's a blue belt I'm matching
Bluebell then there's other people that
go even though they're a black belt I'll
go a white belt and then oh this guy's
pretty good and he starts leveling up I
think I was the start here but then the
problem in competition if you have if
you meet a killer they're going black
ball first so that's why the blind guy
[__] double leg me instantly and I'm
already on my back pin you know yeah
versus I'm like oh black guy's a killer
right this is a [__] killer already
so he's already going okay I can't see
dude I'm gonna [__] I'm gonna [__]
work this [__] and for me I'm
like still like tentative I'm like wait
he's blind I'm still yeah you know
versus like just being a nice guy and
then blind guy's like what a [__] and I
can't even see that you're being a nice
guy that guy had two eye patches
and then so you you replay those moments
in your mind after the match and those
are the kind of like the ones that haunt
you because you're like I felt like such
a [__] yeah yeah for being nice yeah
and you can see and you keep thinking
about the times that you let yourself
down because you know you could have
done better yeah but the only person
standing in your way is yourself and a
blind guy yeah and a blind guy so I was
like you gotta get past the blind but he
doesn't even know that you're in his way
yeah yeah so I think now it's like
that's what that's what I tap into if I
have to like go the extra gear for
almost anything it's like what was my
last like what was my last promise to
myself
so that I don't experience the same
trauma that I feel like I did when I was
a kid we're like I told myself I was
gonna do this and I didn't do it and it
was fully in my control it wasn't
outside circumstances or anything like
that so it sounds like you guys are very
accountable for your actions or trying
to be I don't know if you know you know
what what I tap into which always works
for me is like I think because I grew up
watching Back to the Future so many
goddamn times the I feel like Michael J
fox you know like how he plays Marty
McFly yeah he's in the crazy situation
you could think of but his attitude is
like perfect oh geez yeah so I use humor
to like cope with like even when I got
in that accident with TJ literally
almost dying the whole time I was like
what's next
you know what I mean like I just have
this mentality of like it keeps me like
able to do what I have to do because I
just think of it like like it's a movie
like of course this is happening
everyone can I say someone dude
personally it's just a Ryan
do you want them to leave the room shut
up
no I watched uh Back to the Future
recently like a couple days ago and as I
was watching this I was like
did Marty McFly is Ryan ryanime
oh yeah you remember you remind me of
this [__] you saw similarities
yeah I just feel like it makes sense
when I watch that movie I feel like I
understand you more like his mom fell in
love with them
he's a true [__] dude do you
agree question I don't know man this guy
is real life morning McFly no
Ryan is cool though he's cool as hell
it's pretty cool thanks he's probably
skateboarding through the town and [__]
with no wheels I imagined I was yeah
because last gear he has McFly's car he
had all that for sure outfit but I don't
know outfit I don't know yeah but you
have a crazy uncle
that's not his uncle at all
he's just a guy in the neighborhood that
he became friends with it's a little
weird if you think of it that's a little
weird I thought there's no backstory
yeah yeah it's assumed they did have it
but they took it out fun fact if you're
a super fan
yeah
the backstory okay the backstory is this
is just for the actors to know so they
never told it in the movie but
um Marty got caught by doc just [__]
around one day breaking into his [__]
and then doc just started hiring him and
then they built a friendship I see kind
of weird apprenticeship yeah I would say
like a little bit kind of like it's on
the line yeah
I
thought it was pretty
um interesting because it's one of those
things that we all tap into but never
really talk about and when you've got to
a certain point where you're doing
difficult things right and then the
thing that separates someone who does
the thing that they want to do in life
versus someone who dreams is that
pivotal point
so everyone dabbles in certain
competition or whatever but what you
guys accomplished up to this point
is because you can tap into some source
that keeps you going and that Source I
know at least for myself it's like um it
can be a positive Source or it can't be
a negative Source but it's energy so
like one could be a hateful angry one
and I was now I'm like when I watch
these shows like anime or [__] like
Marvel or whatever I'm like oh that's
what they were talking about it's like
you can use
like the fire yeah and then like you can
tap into the negative side and that's
still energy like Spiderman when his
uncle dies yeah and he looks back he's
like [__] I could have stopped them yeah
and then it's all those things that can
yeah can an event what are you tapping
when you're doing stunts and someone's
just messing you up on set over and over
when someone's just messing me up yeah
when you have to keep getting hit
constantly you report on the SAG or
something
he tap he Taps into the tattletail
but to be honest what goes to my head is
just like
don't disappoint the people who brought
me on oh wow that's a good one so it's
just like constantly like yo if this guy
said subin's good for this then I gotta
do it there's no other option that's
dope man and usually I [__] up but so it
doesn't work well I go up to my boss
after I'm just like yo I'm sorry I tried
[__] you want me to do it again no we're
out of shots we're out of scene tonight
well I tried they ran out of tape hey
boss you want some coffee
you want a haircut what about you
Anthony link what are you tap into
um man
uh I just called ones that I feel like I
resonate a lot with where it's talking
about like don't try to be the best try
to be the only I think when I uh think
about the concept of being the best I I
can get really insecure especially as
like a Creator and stuff like that like
when you're comparing yourself to other
people there's always going to be
somebody better than you just as much as
there's always going to be somebody
that's worse than you but if you really
try to tap into being like the only then
at least you give a lane for yourself to
be where you're supposed to be in that
moment and then try your best version of
yourself there
um I also fail from time to times like
Bar says you know we're kind of like the
jab walkies but not I never said that I
think there's a clip of you saying it
specifically dude you know how crazy
ai's been oh [__] that's [__] crazy
these days
it is crazy Ryan doesn't have time to do
the reels anymore I just saw it on the
hottest guys of all the nations and they
made that okay
but yeah just that just that constant
attempt to be the only be the only one
that's kind of gangster you're the only
around nothing good
yeah like one of my favorite Fighters
was Genki sudo back in the day and it
wasn't like he he was like his he was
trying to be the best he was just being
the only so like he's like [__]
people up and then after after his
fights in the UFC he's talking about
world peace and he has like every single
flag and then you see him his his uh his
footage in Japan and he's [__] like
doing these dancing [__] routines
that are so good though yeah and it's
just him they're so good and I'm like
that's so cool it's like that's just him
doing him and then like he's living up
to his own standard and he's just happy
about it yeah oh my God that's tight but
then people that are like if there only
is being the best that's dope too yeah
that's a double whammy imagine like
you're the only and you're the best wow
that one probably likes that guy that's
why you become that girl
overachiever yeah the guy doesn't have
friends
oh
foreign